hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to talk about my ninth Kum Joe so
eight and nine pair up nicely together
they both come from this Kishi position
so reaching up on top um my ninth or
sorry my eighth Kum Joe or my ninth Kum
Joe is cyto sensei's first K Joo and um
it's the one that I think most people
who study wama weapons know best with
the Joe because tend most teachers tend
to start at 1 and work through one um
but to me it's full a lot of detailed
strange stuff like and not that it's
really strange it's just tactically
understanding what's happening is
complex and so we're going to talk about
that today and to me it's better to save
that to the end so it's like people
already have an idea of how to work with
the Joe and how it tactically comes
together before they start working on
this Kum Joe that I think is actually
rather complicated so I'm gonna get Josh
over here we're going to go to work
Josh all right so let's talk about my
ninth Kum Joe um this is like the
sensei's first Kum Joe this is Kum Joe I
think a lot of people know but is very
problematic and tactically complex I
think there's a bunch of stuff to make
it make sense you got to understand a
lot of things and I think it does make
sense and I think it's a good form I
think there's some cool stuff in it but
it's complex so let's let's hit some of
that stuff
today okay so just like from my fourth
form down this starts with me and Joe
Kamai and Josh and ski Kamai at Josh's
distance so in the form basically what's
going to happen is Josh is going to
shoot a choku ski uh as he does that I'm
going to step off to the side I'm going
to Kishi ski him in response he's going
to mawashi Bar this to the side he's
going to come in for me I'm going to
step off to the side with Banji noai
catching it then I'm going to use a
jodan guch he's going to turn back and
catch it he's going to whip it away with
a Masashi bar I'm going to come around
and use jodan guch or renzoku chomi to
hit him in the head um so uh and that
last Masashi barai cite the Sensei
doesn't really do do it the school I
learned it from does do it and I like it
because it's a nice additional mhi bu
and you can see mhi BU from a different
position but that's basically the way
you'd see the form okay so this form
super complicated when you're in this
position it's a harder position in lots
of ways and I think it might feel okay
if you've done it a whole bunch but it
is not as good as just grabbing it like
this this is an easier way to to grab
right um but this is a hard way to grab
but if I grab this way I'm not really
going to be nicely set up for a choku
and I could if I stepped to the other
side but so I'm reaching up on top like
this to deliver a ski so this in my
opinion has to be a guy who's kind of
comfy with stuff right now another thing
that's happening is when Josh is
launching this he's doing a subet ski in
the form and that's so I can kind of
time it so he goes subet ski and that's
the way you see it in the forums but he
could also just be launching a choku ski
so if he's doing that I have to be
really fast in order for him to do that
and me hop off to the side and choku ski
him right so this we're talking about a
person who's faster than the other
person so in this the the she the person
who's doing the form has to be faster
right so just have to be faster
otherwise you're not going to get that
off right so in this form we're seeing a
good idea which is I should attack an
attack so that's that's not a bad idea
but the problem with that is I just have
to be really fast and especially from
this configuration this is kind of like
a a very specialized kind of thing okay
so first of all I think this forms has
to be for uh someone who's doing that
second part of it is
Josh Midway through has to recognize
that I'm attacking stop there and knock
this away now this is a guy who's
Computing things fast now because it's a
hand action for a foot action I think
tact technically he can get it off it's
just a lot right so if he were to finish
his whole ski and then try to do the
Masashi barai the Masashi baray would be
pointless because he would have already
got hit right so he has to do it in the
middle of my action and in my opinion
teaching students to do this is really
hard because actually let's switch rules
real quick because what has to happen is
as I come in here I have to not continue
forward then I have to Circle boom knock
it out of the way and then I have to
thrust through right so it would look
like this right
so okay and that's a lot it's a it's a
lot to to pull off and could you pull it
off sure absolutely but it's hard right
so tactically this is some very fast
decisionmaking and some physically very
capable people right so this is already
kind of kind of super hard okay the rest
of it makes kind of nice sense the the
joden guch is what would happen if we
were at range right which is the
opposite of cyes second form so cyes one
and two really kind of have the same
idea of going uh using the defense here
and going into jodan gishu and two cyes
two goes to the leg um that's my uh five
and
uh my six uh and um and that uh that is
uh the same kind of idea done from two
different situations so that's nice it's
nice to you go both high and low um
seeing the high Masashi bar is really
nice but this beginning is a mess right
so Josh is coming in I'm able to get
offline fire my shot and he's able to
defend that shot so lots going on then
this we're in pretty pretty familiar
territory here he comes in I defend here
I'm at distance so I just go ahead and
take the distance he steps back and
defends now what's nice here let's
rewind that a little bit so Josh could
also do other options so if he was in
range and I was going forward at all he
could just do first form answer and stab
me right here Bo right so that's good
okay if he thought he couldn't because
I'm backing up he could use second form
answer for this bunk right but because
I'm fast right and he's not able to
quite get there he kind of gets there a
little bit and then boom right so so
that's why we're getting that and we
that's kind of a nice thing to see and
you also see that in my third form um
but it's nice to see that
like uh I can't quite get off the move I
want and so we kind of make this other
one work um so that's really nice and
the high uh Masashi barai is really nice
to see because from this position Josh
is making a mhi baray here so he can use
that as a clearing action which is
really great we normally just see it
down here so in this form we see both of
those but up here we see that and we see
how I can turn that into ruch chomi so
those are nice things to see um I think
if you already understood the system you
could pretty much put that stuff
together um but that opening tactical
set really takes a lot of talking too
about why it comes off that way so um
that's my ninth form and I save it for
the end because it's just kind of a mess
to talk about uh I think that's that's
what I can say about it right now I'm
Chris ran Joshua th my MCD is behind
that camera right there see you in the
next video